welcome Exedy rockstars I'm Erik Bosse
and ventures endgame directors the Russo
brothers keep teasing remaining hidden
easter eggs because apparently the
coolest way to watch superhero movies is
like a detective reviewing security
camera footage next frame next frame
next oh I think I saw a glare there my
wife won't talk to me specifically these
two jokesters claimed that a nova cameo
was hidden in the movie and then they
quickly back pedaled on it saying it was
just a joke on their part but that
clarification came after I went out and
freakin pound him I don't know is that
possible can you find an easter egg in a
movie that the director said doesn't
really exist well we're gonna find out
because cameo or no cameo Nova is still
a very interesting character with a
future in the MCU that has been
confirmed and we need to discuss it
spoiler warning in case you wanted to go
through this bait-and-switch yourself
but you have summoned me and I am your
MCU spirit guide and my job is to make
your breakthroughs for you ok here's
what the Russo brothers initially said
and then endgame QA how do you guys not
have any Nova Corp member in a fight
against Thanos loved the movie but just
boggles my mind didn't even have to be
Richard Ryder I look closely at that
scene again dear and you will see there
are thousands of people yeah you will
see Richard Ryder in the background of a
shot Easter Egg and as many of us
suspected this was more of a troll stir
egg because when asked for clarification
they email back saying this one was a
joke on our part but why did everyone
lose their minds over this well for
those less familiar with Nova Nova is
part of the Nova Corps from the Marvel
Comics in the MCU the Nova Corps is the
Defense Forces of xander that we saw in
the first guardians of the galaxy led by
Glenn Close as Nova prime Ronnie Rio and
featuring john c reilly as roman day in
the comics nova was introduced as a kind
of cross between Peter Parker and Hal
Jordan Green Lantern in the DC Comics
DC's Green Lantern Corps was one of the
many things Marvel Comics saw and
thought wouldn't be cool if we had a
version of that
Richard Reiter began as a kid randomly
selected to possess a cosmic Nova Force
leader of the broader Nova Corps
originally responsible for the defenses
of solely the planet of zan dark which
exists mostly in the Marvel comic
is a place that just keeps getting
wrecked before the Nova Corps widened
their jurisdiction to the whole galaxy
as the superhero Nova himself can fly
and use the energy of the Nova force to
fire blasts and open portals in space
over the years Richard Ryder Nova left
and then rejoined the Nova Corps and the
Corps itself is structured in two
separate tiers with a base level
corpsman than the millennion
and the denarian and then the top tier
centurion from which Nova prime is
selected Nova prime is the one who can
access all aspects of the Nova force and
fuses with the Zen darian world mind
which is kind of an organic
supercomputer similar to the Kree
supreme intelligence and the movies the
irani Royale Nova prime doesn't appear
to have the Nova force superpowers it's
more of a government position but maybe
she represents an old guard Nova Corps
that will be replaced by a new Nova
Corps Nova Corps 2.0 led by a new Nova
prime Marvel head Kevin Feige has
confirmed that Nova is a character on
their board of future Marvel titles and
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn has brought up Richard Reiter has a
name Marvel was definitely considering
bringing into the MCU at some point now
before the Russo brothers admitted that
the Nova Easter Egg was a joke
I did spend the better part of an
afternoon scouring these am battle of
earth looking for this guy
every blip in blur a suspect after all
we have been learning that apparently
the VFX artists have hidden all kinds of
visual details in the background that
are just not visible with the naked eye
like that Green avatar of our names zona
in the shield basement which is so just
in the background that really it's more
of a kind of faint green smudge that's
right all of shields infiltrated by a
booger and despite the in-game final
battle being filled with flying specks
plasti and energy beams at each other in
background aerial dogfights I thought I
actually found Nova the moment Howard
the Duck appears when he marches out
with the other Ravagers from a portal
from contrack sia some fans were saying
some of those background people look
like nova but really they're just
Ravagers with different color skin but
she is before you see howard the duck
milliseconds before he pause and move up
from howard's position along a 1 o'clock
vector between the yellow skin ravager
in the blue skin one with the widow's
peak beneath that neon coatrack see a
billboard you can see the glare of what
looks like a golden metallic helmet and
folks I
was ready to run with that blur and
shout boom looking for this it's a it's
just a glare no real red Nova logo or
blue suit or like three notes on a chest
but still boom and even though this was
really just nothing I wasted a lot of
time hey it was still worth it do you
think about the ways no book could still
be introduced the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but think about it the current
Marvel timeline exists in a universe in
which is and are presumably remains
devastated from whatever Thanos did to
them to obtain that power stone the Nova
Corps is likely in ashes and it is from
those ashes from which the new Nova
prime or simply Nova could rise Nova
could be a subplot and the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 movie or even a
supporting character in the next Captain
Marvel film both of which we know are in
the pipeline but do you think Nova could
actually be hidin Avengers in game
despite the directors denial of this and
do you think Nova's should be introduced
in the third guardians of the galaxy
film or the next Captain Marvel film or
his own solo film comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on twitter
and instagram @ ee vas and subscribe to
new rock stars for breakdowns of
theories about everything Marvel thank
you for joining me and you know perhaps
the real answer of this mystery Nova
cameo was right under our noses just
zoom in on those letters and OVA what do
you got no nah
slide over no that's right no
[Music]